mary trump welcome to the show
thank you for having me uh
i i'm i i'm gonna start by asking you
what what makes you a typical trump
a typical oh wow i don't think
um i don't know that i have anything in
common
with anybody in my family honestly uh
that's a fascinating question i i've
never really thought about it because
in some ways i've always felt so outside
of them
because my interests have always been so
different
uh like across the board uh politically
intellectually um you know i like to
read
for example so i
i honestly don't think i have anything
in common
with uh anybody left in my my dad's
family which
i think is a good thing honestly but you
do have the genes
after all uh yeah
well there is a family resemblance that
i cannot deny
so i i was
i i should be honest to say that i i was
expecting
uh a bit more uh what should i say
uh lavish interiors and gold-plated
you know more gold
yes it's true that um
my grandfather was enormously wealthy
and could have afforded as extravagant a
lifestyle as he wanted
but he was also a very provincial person
um first of all his gra his mother
was a very austere person and
um he also lived through the depression
so i think there was um
a reticence about being lavish
in any way so uh
at least compared to other people with
his wealth he lived
pretty modestly actually i i didn't
understand when i was a kid
just how much money my family had
so as they after all
they were quite wealthy uh how how would
christmas be that
i it was it was probably the most
extravagant
uh occasion during the year um
we had in my grandparents house there it
was uh there was a
a round um
what do you call it um entryway
and i'm so sorry about this and
it was like a 30-foot ceiling so every
christmas my grandfather would get like
a 25-foot christmas tree
but my grandmother would decorate it
like she would get on a ladder
you know she would put the lights on
herself so she had no help
so on the one hand it was um very
overdone but on the other hand it was
just my grandmother doing it
single-handedly so you know
it's like they didn't know how to enjoy
uh
their wealth at all what about gifts
um well they were terrible gift givers i
have to say
um donald and his first wife ivana were
the worst
so basically everybody in my family had
to give everybody else a gift so
i had to give all of my aunts and uncles
gifts and so it was ridiculous like
there would be dozens and dozens and
dozens of packages under the tree and
since nobody really put a lot of thought
into it nobody ever got anything that
really
suited them necessarily you know we
would get clothes that were the wrong
size
or um you know
we would get something that was of of no
interest to us whatsoever
but you know donald and ivana took it to
a whole
new level um ivana for example was
famous
for re-gifting so in other words
she would get a gift from somebody or
get something from a luncheon she had
attended
re-wrap it and then give it to somebody
else's
christmas present uh one year the very
first year
she was in the family she gave me a
three pack of underwear which
you know i could use obviously but it
wasn't exactly a great christmas present
so um it was sometimes hard not to feel
insulted but
my brother and my older cousin and i we
just sort of made a joke out of it
because
you know what are you gonna do uh
your your grandfather was was donald
trump's father
uh uh and how close
would you say you were to him
to my grandfather yeah not
at all um partially because
my grandfather had no use for girls um
but mostly because he
um did not like my mother my uh
my dad's wife obviously and he
did not respect or care for my father
who was
his oldest son either so i kind of
suffered
from from being their child as well uh
so he was he was pretty dismissive of me
uh throughout the course of my life and
it wasn't exac
it wasn't until he had actually
forgotten who i was after he developed
alzheimer's that he actually started
being kind to me
so how about how about his his wife
were you close i
actually was very close with my
grandmother eventually
um not really when i was a kid because
uh
i don't know we just you know we it
wasn't an affectionate family
and i was at their house all the time
but
we didn't really have a lot of
conversations
necessarily but a few years after my dad
died
i felt that it was my responsibility to
be in her life
or to have her in my life so i made a i
made a real effort
and we got to be very very close um
i'd say in the maybe four years after my
dad died
until my grandfather died uh so
you know i i saw her two or three times
a week we talked on the phone every day
so so how well would you say that
you got to know your uncle the president
the thing about donald is that there's
not much to know
uh he is literally exactly the same
when he's in front of a camera as he is
when he's with his family or when he's
with
the people he works with so when that's
the case there really
isn't much underneath the surface
um so when i
worked for him he hired me in night i
think it was 1993
to write his third book for him and that
was really
the first time as an adult that i spent
that much time with him i saw him every
day
and we traveled together sometimes and
it was remarkable how little
i got to know him because as i said
there just wasn't that much
to know what you see with donald is
pretty much what you get
why do you think he wanted you to write
that book
um because i went to tufts university
and i had written a letter
to the dean of students recommending one
of my professors
for tenure and after i graduated
the dean sent this letter to donald
basically to say look mary loves tough
so much
it was sort of a fundraising ploy right
but when donald read the letter what he
saw
was that i was really good at
complimenting people
so he thought that that would be of use
in somebody who wrote his next book
um your the way you describe your
grandfather
it it it must have been a kind of a
tough upbringing
for your father fred the older brother
and also for
for donal uh but they
they dealt very differently with that
upbringing
yeah it was a very difficult household
to grow up in
and um i i think all of the children
all five of them suffered but
particularly my dad because he was the
oldest son
he was the namesake he was supposed to
take over the empire
and from a fairly young age i imagine my
grandfather
saw things in my dad he did not admire
um you know he wasn't tough he was
actually quite sensitive
he was kind uh he was funny
and he had interests outside of
real estate you know he loved boats and
fishing and he went on to be
become a pilot and uh because he didn't
fit the mold of what my grandfather
expected him to be
he punished him very severely my dad was
subjected to
lots of humiliation growing up and um
you know donald witnessed this because
he was seven and a half years younger
the difference was that eventually
to protect himself really from the same
kinds of abuse my dad got
donald developed personality traits
that you know most people wouldn't
admire
you know he was a bully he would do
anything to win
including lying cheating and stealing
but my grandfather actually
did value those characteristics so they
kind of became hardened
and you know that's that's why we see
how donald is today
honestly so so so in your view
how how do you think he might respond to
losing
i mean if that's gonna happen
very badly i you know we we need to be
really
clear-eyed about what might happen first
of all
he's going to do anything in his power
to make sure that doesn't happen
uh and we already see he's cheating
already um you know by
telling people that it isn't safe to
vote by mail in the middle of a pandemic
by telling people that if joe biden wins
it
it will have been rigged you know that's
cheating because he's using the power of
the oval office
to get that message across if however
uh joe biden does win um
it kind of depends on the margin of
victory if it's a huge landslide and
nobody can pretend
that it's an illegitimate result i think
donald is much more likely
to try to spin it as america's loss
you know he was the best thing that ever
happened to this country and we don't
deserve him
so he's going to go do something really
important like
build trump tower in moscow or something
if it's close uh i think we're in for a
very very rough period of time
you you've you've uh called him a
narcissist and and
uh and as you are as a psychologist
uh i i must ask you how how can you give
him a a diagnose without even treating
him
i actually don't diagnose him because
it's technically impossible to diagnose
somebody
who is not your patient you know it
requires a very specific
procedure which he wouldn't submit to
and he's not my patient
so what i what i try to do in the book
is help people
understand how many symptoms he has
of various personality disorders so
um people can see just how
complex his psych psychopathologies
are because you know i think the
diagnosis isn't really that important
it's his behavior that we need to pay
attention to
and if you look at his behavior you can
see that this is not a well
person um
would you um if if you were to
to to lie on your coach what would you
ask him
uh it's so hard for me to imagine
his ever putting himself in that
position um you know i would honestly
i'd ask him to start at the beginning
because that's what we do
um but i'm not entirely sure
we could get anywhere because somebody
with his kinds of disorders
when they do go to therapy which is rare
they claim that the problem is everybody
else
you know they're perfectly fine but it's
the rest of the world
that's causing them grief it's the rest
of the world that's making impossible
for them to function properly
so um you know i
you know one question i might ask him is
what are you so afraid of and it would
be very difficult if not impossible for
him to acknowledge that
but i continue to believe that
donald's biggest problem is that deep
down he is
a terrified little boy and he's never
gotten beyond that
what kind of experience do you have with
him that makes you say that
well you know i've known in my whole
life and i've i've
seen how things have unfolded but i also
have access to
family history you know um
i have stories i was as i said close
with my grandmother i was at one time
close with one of my aunts my dad died
when i was 16
but you know i still had plenty of
stories from him as well
and other people who knew the family so
i can say that with confidence in part
because um it is factually true
that my grandmother became very very ill
when donald was two and a half
and was essentially absent from his life
for about a year
i know that my grandfather was a
sociopath and was incapable
and unwilling to take over her role
so for about a year this toddler had
nobody to soothe him
had nobody to be affectionate had nobody
to tell him that he didn't need to be
afraid
uh and there was nothing done after that
to repair those wounds it only got worse
uh that's a very very terrible time in a
child's life to be abandoned by
the one person in the world who is you
know
your main human connection and mary i'm
sure you're aware of
of the president tweeting uh about you
and your book
uh and uh among other things he wrote
that's uh
he he describes you as a a seldom seen
niece
who knows little about me says
untruthful things about my wonderful
parents who couldn't stand her
well what's your comment on that i'm not
entirely sure
why he thought that that would make me
look bad but
okay
you know he seems to forget that uh if
i'm his niece he's also my uncle
and um i think he also said that i was
unloved from the moment i was born
which i'm not entirely sure what i did
when i was an
infant to make people not love me
but again it's just it's a it's a
commentary
on him and his parents
if that were indeed the case um
so as often happens with donald
he lashes out in a way that ends up
hurting him
um and also i he can say whatever he
wants to about me
it doesn't it doesn't have any impact on
me
but i found it a curious line of attack
he would have been
better served if he just ignored me and
the book entirely
you you are i know you that you are in
the middle of a lawsuit
uh with your family and also you
you written this book i mean do do you
do you at one level
feel that you have betrayed them
willingly
and no uh because they were never loyal
to me
it's i don't see how you can betray
people who were never there for you in
any
capacity that mattered and it's
interesting like i don't
ever hear anybody asking him that
question about whether or not he
betrayed me
so i don't see it that way i see
i wrote the book mostly as an american
citizen
as somebody who's deeply concerned about
what's happening in
my country the lawsuit is really
um a way of getting justice
these were my aunts and uncles who after
my dad died
at the age of 42 committed financial
fraud against me
and kept me out of my fair share out of
my
dad's inheritance so i see the lawsuit
as a way to get my stolen property
returned to me
quite honestly i'm i i wonder because
i'm sitting here with with
uh a tv anchor that has covered many
presidents i i just wonder
when you hear this the my my
interview with with mary klaus what are
your thoughts
well i think a lot about it uh it's a
one-sided story of course because it's
it's one person against the rest of the
family but
i wonder more mary what's happening to
you after you published the book
how are people treating you
um and i agree with you of course it's
it's it's one-sided but i i will say
though
that it's backed up by family history
and stories i was able to get from other
people um
but you're right it's it's decidedly my
point of view
so i encourage everybody to take it with
a grain of salt if necessary
uh in terms of what it's been like after
the book came out
you know we're we're on lockdown because
of cobit so in a really weird way
nothing's changed um i mean i get to
have interesting conversations
via zoom with people i've never met
before so that's
great but um you know
i'm still in my house um i'm i live in
new york
and we got hit very very hard so
i've not really ventured out very much
uh
since march um so
it's a little uh i mean i was gonna say
frustrating but you know so many people
are so much worse off than i am but you
know
in a small way it's frustrating that it
it's it's hard for me to gauge
how the book's been received if it's
having any kind of impact
um but the the extent to which my life
hasn't changed at all
is kind of remarkable and it's because
of cobin
do you have i have um do you have any
contact with with the
anyone in the family no i
don't and i i didn't anticipate that i
would and i understand that i mean
why should they want to have contact
with me um
i think that's completely a completely
fair response
but you know i also went into this with
my eyes wide open
uh these are vindictive people and
you know i had to take the necessary
precautions
because like it or not donald does have
a lot of power
and he does have a lot of followers so
uh you know i've been in a way covet has
also made it easier for me to be careful
i guess what yeah uh
hello um when i was 17 i was an exchange
student in north dakota
you should go there it's a very lovely
place
uh the friends from high school there uh
that's my focus group in the us and they
think
trump is gonna win because they don't
like uh communism
so uh what if the polls are wrong again
oh well i i mean that's why i don't
sleep anymore
because we're all still traumatized from
2016.
um you know it's interesting
in a terrifying way um that
people in north dakota are still able to
have that attitude when first of all
joe biden is as far from a communist as
you can get
and you know still be a democrat
i mean i am so far to the left of joe
biden
it's amazing that anybody can try to
pin the label of socialist or communist
on him
and i think it's it's a condemnation of
our system of education that people
don't even understand what these terms
mean
um but beyond that uh i don't know if
you you have seen the numbers recently
north dakota
is on fire with coven 19 infections
right now
it's absolutely horrifying
i mean they have the highest rate of
infection
i think in the world right now it's like
76 per 100 000
it's through the roof it's a straight
line
up and there's only one person to blame
for this
and yet they're worried that joe biden
might be a communist
it's um it's very concerning because i
think it does suggest
that there's a possib a stronger
possibility than there might otherwise
have been uh
that donald has a shot at it i i hope
that's not the case but
you know it's something we need to take
very seriously
uh mary i know you've been generous with
your time i just have two more questions
and one is from noomi
um sure so we would hi it's
it's uh an honor to meet you and you did
ask if you think your book has some kind
of impact and he does
you know we in europe it's been a lot of
conversations about you and your book
so it's definitely creating waves um
but we just before you came on we were
talking about
um advice and who you would take advice
from and who would you give advice to
who who who guided you who made you
become a person
that has the bravery and the strength to
go against
and stand up for something in in a
situation where it's quite
scary it must be quite scary i mean for
you
uh well first of all thank you for that
i really appreciate it
um and secondly i i think
there i think i'm missing something
because it
didn't feel like it took courage to do
this
it felt like something i had to do i had
an obligation
i had information that could help the
american people
understand the danger we're in um
and it just needed to be done you know
um
because also like i think of bravery and
i think of of
of people who take their families pack
up everything they own and travel
thousands of miles across hostile
territory to seek refuge in a country
that then rejects them
you know that's courage courage in
america to me is being
a person of color raising a black child
uh you know so i guess i i
kind of just compare what i do i've done
to things like that and it doesn't seem
like it really took that much courage
and i'm actually not afraid because
um despite the fact that donald is in a
position of power
i've known him forever and he's the
weakest person i've ever known
so it just it's impossible for me to be
afraid of him
mary finally when was the last time you
met him
i was at the white house uh in april of
2017 for my aunt's birthday parties
uh so that's that's the last time i saw
him
and the time before that was eight years
earlier at my cousin ivanka's wedding
and then eight years before that uh
because the lawsuit kind of makes it
when you sue your family it kind of
makes it difficult to keep having
holidays together
but describe that describe that that
last
meeting you had with him at the white
house how was that
it was actually kind of fascinating in a
way
um it was very stressful but
um when i first saw you know we had a
tour
but i didn't see donald until we got to
the dining room
and he was standing in the entryway and
when he saw me
he pointed at me and he smiled and he
said i specifically
asked for you to be invited which was a
lie
um but it tells you so much about his
psychology because
he knew it was a lie he probably knew i
knew
but he one wanted to take credit for it
and two it was actually charming
right like if i had believed him i would
have been entirely charmed by that
so uh i thought that was
fascinating that he hadn't changed a bit
since i'd last seen him
not surprisingly and this is the very
best way
i'm so sorry was it a surprise to him
that you
came did he know he looked surprised
but um i don't know i don't know if he
saw the list ahead of time or not
i would assume he did so i'm not sure
why he looked as surprised as he did but
it was an odd moment and he also for the
very first time in my life
hugged me which was also kind of
shocking
um and then at the very end after the
meal and we were taking pictures with
him
uh i said to him and this was very early
on in the administration but things are
already going badly
so i said to him don't let them get you
down
and he clenched his teeth and he said
they're not going to get
me um and so far
he's been right
why do you think you said that
i wanted to get under his skin a little
bit
honestly and i don't know i mean i
didn't plan it it just kind of happened
so i've often thought about that too why
did i say that to him
um i think it was a way to get under his
skin without without
appearing to be aggressive about it you
know
um but i'm i'm still not sure
but his answer was kind of perfect and
it wasn't just
what he said it was the way he said it
and the way he clenched his jaw
uh so even then i could see that he was
under the
kind of stress that he'd never been in
in his life
um i'm so grateful that you you
found the time to talk to us from new
york um
if you were to say one nice thing about
your uncle before we wrap up what would
that be
uh first of all i hope you guys will let
me move there if things don't go well
in november of course that will be free
um in all seriousness no
seriousness though um and this isn't
something i
enjoy saying i can't think of one thing
well then uh we'll have to leave it at
that thank you very much
and what should i say good night and
good luck
you too thank you this was wonderful it
was great to meet all of you thank you
very much
hope you enjoyed the clip for more
interesting conversations
please hit subscribe